[Música]
y decimos segundo ayuntamiento de
tijuana
en hit latino su llamada es muy
importante para nosotros por favor
esperen el ranking porque sabemos que lo
más importante es cuidar de la piel de
tu bebé dermatológicamente probados
eso que acabas de escuchar es mi voz y
más que mi voz es un sueño que yo tuve
desde niña recuerdo que siempre me
preguntaban a qué me quería dedicar y yo
siempre supe que quería ser artista yo
cuando cantaba no era normal no era
cantar una canción yo me creía mi
personaje yo era selena quintanilla era
el isea villarreal era quien me pusiera
sobre 7 cava mercurio magneto cuando
jugaba las barbies eran unos dramas yo
quería ser actriz me encantaba escuchar
lo que decía el locutor en la radio
siempre me la pasaba repitiendo los
comerciales y decía yo quiero estar ahí
yo quiero que mi voz se escuche
y así fue este sueño se cumplió hace 15
años y podría decirte que todos los
sueños se cumplen que le eches ganas que
si se puede que motivarte motivarte para
que te vayas aquí empoderado diciendo
que todos los sueños que quieras los vas
a lograr que te la van a poner bien
difícil pero que si se puede y al final
ahí estará tu éxitos esperándote pero no
lo que quiero decirte hoy es que la vida
está llena de oportunidades y hay que
saber tomarlas y no todas las
oportunidades están increíbles pero hay
que tomar riesgos y te vas a caer y unas
caídas van a ser más dolorosas que otras
pero te vas a levantar y al levantarte
entenderás que te caíste para aprender
para mejorar para valorar para crecer
la vida está llena de oportunidades y mi
primera oportunidad fue hace 15 años
cuando una locutora muy reconocida y muy
admirada por mí se mudó a vivir al mismo
edificio que yo cuando la conocí sentí
mariposas en el estómago la tengo de
frente le digo que quiero ser como ella
super intensa y fan pero le digo que es
lo que tengo que hacer y no sé si fueron
los planetas la suerte mi fortuna pero
me invitó a participar en un proyecto de
radio que ella estaba por iniciar con
otro el motor muy reconocido yo no hacía
nada más que contestar el teléfono tenía
una participación microscópica tenía un
apodo que no me dejaron decirles cólera
pero yo le hacía
me sentía fabulosa donde te pongo el
autógrafo cuantos likes me vas a dar yo
me sentía la más exitosa entonces yo me
iba a la universidad me regresaba a mi
casa me iba a la radio a cumplir mi
sueño porque de eso se trata la vida de
ir cumpliendo sueños poco a poco y que
cada vez que te cumple es un sueño te lo
aplauda y te la cola dura fuerte como si
fuera el mayor de tus éxitos
es que siento que la palabra éxito es
una palabra muy pesada pensar en un
éxito nos han enseñado que es una
persona que dirige una empresa ganando
miles y miles de dólares con carros
casas o que ser exitoso es tener mil
millones de seguidores en las redes
sociales que te den like hasta por
respirar haciendo colaboración con
marcas muy importantes o que ser exitoso
es tener reconocimientos ahí en tu pared
el grammy el billboard el oscar el
premio nobel de la literatura de la paz
creo que el éxito va mucho más allá de
lo material de cuánto puedes gastar o de
lo que puedes presumir tengo la certeza
de que el éxito es saberte feliz en el
lugar en el que estás pisando es esa
plenitud que no te cabe en el pecho que
quieres gritar y compartir
es la tranquilidad de irte a casar en la
noche sabiendo que estás cumpliendo tus
sueños y que aunque te falte mucho no
quita el dedo del renglón el éxito es
algo tan personal
mi primer éxito fue a los 18 años nadie
me conocía
hoy tampoco pero antes menos
no tenía carro no había terminado la
universidad me iba caminando a la radio
y no me pagaban un peso
pero nada iba a poder pagar la
oportunidad que yo estaba teniendo de
conocer el medio al cual yo me quería
dedicar de conocer una cabina de radio y
de hacer lo que me apasionaba
la vida está llena de oportunidades
y en esa misma radio llegó mi segunda
oportunidad y esta nuestra tan padre un
locutor que ahí trabajaba un día llegue
me dice bueno y tú que toda la vida la
vas a hacer tú no vas a contestar el
teléfono o qué es lo que quieres hacer y
yo muy segura de mí misma le dije quiero
ser locutora claro y me dice muy bien
lee este texto
leer un texto en radio es algo que
hacemos comúnmente era lo más parecido a
la realidad en ese entonces
con todo el nervio del mundo el miedo y
la angustia lo leo y lo leo espantoso
este hombre no se tocó el corazón y me
dijo que yo jamás iba a poder dedicarme
a la radio
que no me la compraba
no sabes lo dolorosas que fueron sus
palabras me quedé callada
pero no me la creía
no es cierto si me la creíble porque
imagínate yo un profesional de lo que tú
quieres dedicarte dice que no puedes
claro que dolía era tenía 18 años era
una niña persiguiendo sus sueños
claro que me dolió y me pesó y
lamentablemente pasa pasa que te dicen
que no puedes que no lo intentes que no
sirves que no te atrevas y gran error
lo peor que puedes hacer es dejar de
intentar porque al dejar de intentar va
de la mano de que hubiera pasado que
hubiera pasado si yo le hago caso este
señor qué hubiera pasado si yo por
vergüenza no le digo a mi vecina que yo
quería ser como ella que hubiera pasado
no te quedes con eso porque a lo largo
del tiempo va pensando todo esto que
dejaste de intentar y regularmente
dejamos de intentar por miedo por
angustia por incertidumbre por el qué
dirán no sabes la cantidad de personas
que conozco que dejaron de intentar
porque hay es que mi papá quiere que
estudie tal carrera no es que en mi
familia todos son doctores pues yo
también hay no es que sabes que dicen
que es bien mal pagado sacrificamos
nuestros sueños y nuestros deseos por
complacer a los demás y se nos olvida
que a quien debemos de compararte
puede complacer a quien debemos de
aplaudir es a uno mismo
nos pasamos continuamente pensando qué
es lo que van a decir de mí en vez de
concentrarnos en uno mismo
porque la aprobación empieza aquí
empieza aquí se nos olvida que la plaza
dura un minuto
que la gente te olvida te cambia que un
día estás y al día siguiente no y quién
se queda con las infelicidad es los
sueños rotos y el que hubiera pasado
eres tú
la vida está llena de oportunidades y mi
gran oportunidad de cumplir mi sueño de
locutora llegó un año después hago
casting junto con cuatro personas que
doy yo
15 de agosto del 2007 jamás voy a
olvidar esa fecha
sus nervios esas ganas esa ilusión esa
felicidad de alcanzar lo que cree es
inalcanzable porque un día te dijeron
que no servía así que no podías contra
la falta de experiencia habiendo
sacrificado cosas personales porque la
oportunidad viene acompañada muchas
veces del sacrificio de que mi sueño de
irme de intercambio universitario por
conquistar mi sueño profesional ya 14
años ya había abierto micrófono por
primera vez no me arrepiento ni un
segundo la radio ha traído consigo las
mejores oportunidades profesionales he
podido conducir eventos masivos
entrevistar a gente súper importante
he podido dar conferencias y me convertí
en actriz
no de hollywood pero sí de doblaje y ese
es otro gran sueño cumplido la radio ha
traído consigo las mejores
satisfacciones he conocido a gente
increíble y a otra que lo tanto también
tuve la oportunidad de conocer al hombre
de mi vida
y esta historia es para que te caes es
como de novela pero no tengo mucho
tiempo pero te puedo decir que ya
tenemos cinco años juntos y dos niños
increíbles y sin temor a equivocarme te
digo que mi familia es mi mayor sueño y
mi más grande éxito
la vida está llena de oportunidades
y unas torretas que frenan te paralizan
y eso me pasó en el 2016 cuando tuve de
frente a la muerte
este mes
que tuve la oportunidad de conocerme
en esa línea delgada de la vida y la
muerte me doy cuenta que tenía que
empezar a vivir
pero de vivir en serio empezar a tomar
las riendas y saber a dónde voy
esta oportunidad de empezar a valorar a
la gente que me quería y que está ahí y
que yo daba por hecho
y de ser hablado a personas que se
decían amistades y que iban estar para
siempre y no estaban
estarás de noviembre del 2016
tengo la oportunidad de vivir pero
escucha de vivir de tomar las riendas y
el 17 de agosto del 2017 en el de doy la
bienvenida a mi primer hijo
la vida es tan justa
está bien entendido porque había tenido
esa oportunidad una vez más
y desde hace casi cuatro años he podido
ir de la mano de mis grandes dos
pasiones que es la radio y la maternidad
y no quiero sobre romántica a mí también
me dijeron que no a mi novia te dijeron
que no servía que no podía que no lo iba
a lograr no es tomar las mejores
decisiones tal vez y no aprovechar todas
las oportunidades me ha dolido me ha
costado me he quedado noches sin dormir
preguntándome si lo que estoy haciendo
es lo que realmente me apasiona y lo que
quiero entregados mis sueños a personas
que nos han hecho pedazos y me he
quedado en la riva sintiéndome sumamente
vacía y sola
pero la vida
está llena de oportunidades
y cada vez que caigo
en con la oportunidad de levantar y
volver a empezar
esta es mi voz y hoy tengo la
oportunidad de cumplir un sueño más
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]